The Android App Sandbox
does a great job
of keeping apps
separate by default.
But what can you do when the
provided level of isolation
doesn't match your
application's model?
Hi, I'm Geremy Condra,
and in this video,
we'll be talking about how you
can use the Android Platform
Support for different
isolation models
to make your app more
robust and more secure.
What you see here is
a loose model of some
of the most important
layers of isolation
Android provides--
SELinux protections
that separate applications
from system components.
You see Linux User,
a UID separation,
which keeps separate
apps separate.
And you see the process
level separation
between app components.
So let's start off talking
about process separation.
When Zygote spawns
an application,
that application generally
gets its own process.
This prevents other applications
from modifying its memory
and isolates one app
against a crash in another.
So the fact that your app and
someone else's terrible app
are on the same phone doesn't
impact your app's experience.
It also isolates the application
from system components
and system components
from each other.
Zooming in a little
bit, we can see
that two apps which
don't share a process
can still communicate in a
variety of ways, such as binder
or the intent system, or over
legacy mechanisms like pipes
or sockets.
The thing to take
away from this is
that process separation
isn't very restrictive.
Since you can still talk
across these boundaries,
it's easy to get good
isolation with little cost.
And of course, when we're
talking about isolation here,
what we really mean is that
if one process dies or gets
compromised, other processes
can continue to run correctly.
So that's the default model.
And it's a good one for
a huge variety of apps.
But what happens if that
basic model doesn't give you
the isolation you need?
What do you do when you want
to isolate one part of your app
from another-- like,
say, a crashy service
or a network-aware component--
from something that
handles keys or
other sensitive data?
Fortunately, Android's
got your back.
Activities and
services both support
the Android process attribute.
This allows you to specify
exactly what process
you want to run your code in
and getting a new one spawned
for that component if it
doesn't already exist.
In this example,
we have the service
that we don't want taking
down the rest of our app
if it crashes.
By specifying that it should be
run in a process called colon
crashy, we make sure that
Android will run the service
in a new process created
explicitly for this purpose.
Once you're done,
the set of processes
looks a little more like this.
Because colon crashy and the
app processor are separate,
crashy can go down and not
take down the rest of the app.
You can also use this to better
restrict your IPC endpoint.
In this model, colon
crashy won't wind up
indirectly talking to
the IPC endpoints needed
by other components.
So why do we need the
other layers of isolation?
Why not just use
processes for everything?
The reason we don't use process
separation for everything
is because it doesn't
come with a different set
of persistent credentials.
So while another
process might not
be able to modify your memory,
if it has the same UID,
it'll have the same
permissions, it'll
be able to read and write
the same files, et cetera.
As a result, besides
being separated
by process boundaries,
Android applications
are also generally
run as their own user.
This forms the basis
for the App Sandbox,
as well as the separation
between application home
directories.
In this way, Android provides
a kernel-enforced guarantee
that the application's
data can only
be modified by that
application, unless the app
decides otherwise.
This gives a ton of flexibility
and control to the application.
There are two exceptions to
this rule that every app gets
its own UID-- shared UID
and isolated process.
Let's talk about
shared UID first.
In this diagram, apps B and
C are marked shared UID,
while app A is not.
Applications marked
shared UID and signed
with the same keys
are able to do
almost anything
the other can do.
So from the security
perspective,
marking two
applications shared UID
means that they can be treated
as essentially the same app.
And that's sometimes useful
to help break up applications
or provide access to
resources in interesting ways.
But in security, we more often
get the opposite question.
What do I do if I want to break
one app into several security
contexts instead?
And that's where isolated
process comes in.
To see why it's
valuable let's return
to the example of
the crashy service.
Especially for native code,
it may not make sense just
to isolate yourself
from the possibility
that your code will crash.
If the code is really suspect,
like certain kinds of renderers
or media codecs,
you may not want
to have very much to do
with that code at all.
In fact, you may want to run
it in a completely separate
processing user-- essentially,
as its own separate app.
And that's exactly what
isolated process does.
The net result looks
something like this,
with app A split
into two components.
Each is in a different
user and process,
meaning that the isolated
part of the application
is as separate from app
A as other apps are.
So when should you use
process, and when should you
use isolated process?
Use process when the isolated
code is pure Java, when
it doesn't contain an
interpreter or similar,
or when it needs to interact
with other processes
on your behalf.
Use isolated process
when the isolated code
is native code, when it
performs complex operations
like rendering or
encoding, when it contains
an interpreter or
JIT, and when it
doesn't need to
run as your user.
That's it for isolation
for Android app developers.
Be sure to check out the
other videos in this series,
and thanks for watching.